[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
si l'allemagne pour le ratage ennahda
patronat se dessine la
petite histoire
deux heures ont décidé d'y participer
et moi
après
des altercations entre
ils sont séparés dos à
dos d'âne et amis des mazières et
d'autres qui nécessitent
habitude
de deux mois fâché l'alisier iront à des
documents allaient souffrir
et toujours qui va remettre à l'appel
d'un homme a des
visions illinois
construire en 2010 ou faire et qui dit
même plus voir son frère saisi
le matériel
d'autres rapidement
[Musique]
à l'eau
et
pour les dents de scie ne l'ont pas fait
assez de mal entre le beau jeune
classe de terminale
beau de mentir fait que
faire comment sa série
il nous faut son feu vert
politique
[Musique]
qui dit pas le contraire
par les eaux
[Musique]
c'est ce qu'on appelle une bonne
de la consignation
et ben moi aussi
capoue didot vous parlions tous les
besoins
de prison social
dans de gagner nous avons constaté que
l'édition de profits
le terrain en côte d'ivoire pendant la
course on donnera
quatre veines pour travailler ou là une
conciliation et les questions de
cohésion sociale en côte d'ivoire qui
vous informe des -17
ans qui nous ont dit si les oat 10 ans
oat ou non rencontre à poitiers au
niveau des entités étaient présents avec
le cardinal temps
à leurs agents du mi6 et d'une immense
la crise
postélectorale à quito
nous avons appris que des retraités
[Musique]
nous avons de nous pardonner
nous sommes à l'été se profile
je pense que
si
on
vous dit tout nous allons prier a confié
un
autre
[Musique]
titre on doit alors une autre côté du
sud est automatiquement de 18 ans il
était malheureusement les images on
table sur les devants en face
des toutous par owni qui est en conflit
ou de
vautours d'une part du fils on a failli
arriver les autorités
n'ont pas loupé les actions du monument
nous en action
le cadre de concertation de nos vies
infinies tissés entre les militaires des
pouvoirs c'est le cas depuis le temps
que la natation et l'ont bien
compris
l'idée est
aussi nous allons aller dès la descente
de terroriser à paris
7e
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]